yeah usually they'd be working in
offices or design labs for shoe
designers soft drink manufacturers
supermarkets a dig around rain and
marshes on the banks of the Thames in
Essex an unpleasant reminder of where
some of their products unfortunately end
up notice other kind of the small type
pellets that are they raw material of
the plastic in the first place so these
are the things that end up making the
bottles that we reshape and design into
things some of our best-known brands
haven't always been seen as pulling
their weight on the issue of plastic
waste
so now charities set up by Prince
Charles are encouraging them to take
responsibility I don't know of anyone
within the packaging industry that
deliberately goes out to say I'm going
to put too much packaging in the market
or I'm going to over package your
product that's not what happens it's how
we manage consumer behavior it's how we
manage design to make it as good as it
can be seeing the problem is one thing
coming up with solutions is another
meetings like this are a chance to put
their corporate differences to one side
and share innovative ideas taking that
shampoo bottle and actually making
another shampoo bottle out of it or
making building materials out of it
putting it back into the economy and
making good use of it rather than chuck
it into a hole in the ground we can
engage our customers in a fun and
amusing and engaging ways to try and
help me to understand it but without
working with lots of other organizations
and manufacturers and retailers we can't
really get to the cause we're now
experimenting with cotton wool bugs that
you can flush down the toilet the
dissolve on contact with sewage so that
in effect we're starting to see what if
this is a consumer behaviour how do we
then allow that to happen but in a way
that is sustainable then there is
changing the habits of their customers I
certainly didn't realize but it seems
that our recycling habits vary depending
on which room in the house
we're in so in the kitchen 90% of us
recycle whereas moved to the bathroom
and only 50% of people think about what
happens to their shampoo bottles and
those cotton wool butts in the past
businesses and customers have blamed
each other for poor levels of recycling
or bombarding us with packaging now
there does seem to be a changing tide of
opinion that only by working together
can we stop what's being described as a
plastic smog Rihanna Mills Sky News